all right hot topic
yes hot topic uh where'd you grow up
where are you from originally um
i'm from atlanta georgia atlanta and
tell me about your childhood you had
both your parents when you were young
i didn't have my father um my father was
in prison when i was born and
he died shortly maybe when i was like
four years old
i'm sorry how would you describe your
childhood
um it was okay i mean
now that i'm older and i look back um i
could say that
you know a lot of stuff that um happened
to me was um
kind of in my own making um i had a good
childhood
when you say stuff that happened to you
what do you mean i mean um
i blame my mother
for allowing a lot of men to be around
me
being that my father wasn't there my
mother was a prostitute
and yeah and i didn't know that that's
what it was i just thought she had a lot
of men friends
and um so being that
she uh had a lot of men friends there
was a lot of men around me
and so i was molested when i was younger
from the age of four to about 13.
oh my god yeah yeah i didn't know that
that's what it was
um and it was kind of it was okay
up until the point where um somebody
found out
did you say anything i didn't but my
friend who spent the night did
i didn't want her to you know because
for me it was fine what was going on was
fine because i was getting everything i
wanted
i got that from my mom because my mother
used men
to get to take care of us you know and
so being that i knew that
i just wanted to keep that under wraps i
didn't want anybody to find out because
i knew it would
take away from what we had going on
my mother also suffered from mental
illness and i didn't know that either
she had split personalities and whenever
she would drink
or use or whatever she did um her mind
and her body would separate she becomes
someone else
and my mother sold me to men to get what
she wanted
which was crap um no i think my mother
did heroin
okay and she drank a lot of alcohol and
she smoked marijuana
but i didn't know this is what she did
she went in the bathroom a lot of times
or made me go in my room and she had
friends over and i wasn't allowed to
come out
until it was just a man you know and
she'd leave the room
and leave me with that man and certain
things would happen
you know and um i thought that it was
okay because
that's what she was doing you know a lot
of i slept with my mom
i'm an older child so i would see
certain things and when i would see
these things
i would try to perform them just like
she did also she would have sex in the
bed with you
yeah no not with me but she'd have sex
in the other room
and i i you know being that i was mama's
girl you know i
get up and i go and look and see what
she was doing when she told me stay in
my room i never stayed in my room
you know i was going to look and peek
and see what she was doing and so
when these men would approach me i would
just try to perform as she did
you know um she never told me what to do
you know she never said we never
discussed it or anything like that
it was just when a man came in the room
and he did you know touched me the way
he touched her i just did what she did
you know and this started at what age at
four at four i was sitting on the
steering wheel of a cadillac
um and i was being um
he was eating me out basically um when i
was four years old
or he used to work for this company that
um
this guy's work for this company called
western craft
was a car they made cardboard and in
this warehouse there was
long train tracks and he would
my mom would get drunk and he'd take me
and we're supposed to be going shopping
and
we'd go shopping but afterwards we'd go
down these long train tracks
and he'd have a blanket in his hand and
he would take me like up on the
you know freeway off ramp and his bushes
and brush and all that stuff
and we'd go in the bushes and he laid
the blanket down and he'd eat me out
and told me give him head and i did that
um up until i was like maybe i would say
seven eight and then he showed me
porno you know he would buy a what you
got white port
wine and um and have me drink it with
him
and watch porno with him and
and i'd give him a head and he'd eat me
out
and so i did that for many years
and it's quite a childhood yeah i mean
basically like i said if i didn't know
that it was wrong
if my mother would have told me that it
was wrong or there was someone there to
tell me that these are the things i'm
not supposed to be doing
um then i probably would have told
someone sooner or i probably wouldn't
have done it
but i didn't know anything was wrong
with it you know he wasn't hurting me or
anything like that and i was getting
what i wanted
were you upset and crying or is this
something that you did that's something
i did
my mom did so you know i just felt like
i said i followed her footsteps you know
i did what she did she wasn't crying
she had money and clothes and everything
else afterwards so you know
i was infatuated with campus patches i
had 21 of them
i wanted everyone that came out you know
a collection so i knew what i had to do
to get that cabbage patch
you know i knew what i had to do or if i
wanted to go knott's berry farms
or if i wanted to treat my friends to go
and he paid for it then i knew what i
had to do
you learned your lesson on how to get
what you want early yeah
yeah there were other guys as well
um well there was just this one guy my
mom had for
many years um when i was probably about
five there was this one guy that was on
the
i was also very jealous of men touching
my mother
i didn't like them to touch her i didn't
want them close to her
because i felt like it takes away from
my time with my mom you know there was
really a lot of men that came through so
a lot of time was taken away
i didn't get to spend that much time
with my mom and i wanted to so i was
jealous of these men that would come
especially if they spent the night or
something like that you know i have to
go in my room now i don't get to sleep
with my mom
and um so there was this one man i woke
up in the middle night and he was on the
sofa
and i um didn't like the fact that he
was there and i knew that once
he woke up what was going to happen and
so i
chose to go behind the sofa and set the
stuff on fire set them on fire
and um i had to go seek help after that
for a while
i had to do some therapy um but yeah i
set him on fire
um i just i guess it was i didn't feel
like it i didn't want to be with him i
didn't want him touching me
i didn't even want him at our house you
know i just wanted to be with my mom
so um yeah
and there was some other um as i got
older or other incidents
i didn't i wasn't too provocative i was
really
timid and shy i still am a little bit
um i didn't you would never think that i
would be into something like that
you know i kept everything really quiet
i didn't want anybody to know
and when i didn't want to perform these
acts
i would have a girlfriend or somebody
else spend the night you know
and i knew that if it was the wrong
person who spent the night
and he touched them that they were going
to tell so i made sure that i just asked
this one girl all the time crystal to
spend the night
with me because i knew she wasn't gonna
tell but
it came to that point where he decided
not to mess with me that night that
he's gonna go mess with her and i begged
him not to because
i knew that after so many times of doing
it and
her keeping quiet she eventually she was
gonna tell you know
and she told and she ran out the door
and i ran out after her
and i knew that it was all over after
that you know
um they sent me to a foster home
and they didn't take him to jail
and that kind of was weird you know i
don't so much remember
talking to anyone telling anyone what
had happened
i just remember going to a foster home
and um
staying there for a while and that
separated me from my mom
and shortly after i went to go live with
my grandmother you know
my grandmother knew that my mom had an
illness but i never told her
what happened when i was with my mom you
know
so she never knew but i think around the
age of um
16 i began liking boys
really liking boys not men but boys that
were my age
and um a little bit more fast than they
were
you know i i'm ready to hump and kiss
you know what i mean they're like whoa
wait a minute
you know um how do you know how to do
all this you know what i mean but
um i hadn't actually had intercourse i
didn't have intercourse until i was 18.
and um at 16 and i believe
there was a my daughter's father was 32.
yeah he was 32 and he didn't have sex
with me that he waited until i was 18
but
soon as i turned 18 we had sex and i got
pregnant
as soon as i had sex i had a baby um
but i was pretty much um while i was
with him
he would have me go out and there was a
track
called colorado in pasadena matter of
fact
and i went on a colorado boulevard and
he would leave me with these other girls
these older women and in order for them
in order for me to
um stay with them or be in their room or
whatever
i had to make money so they pretty much
showed me how to prostitute myself
on the streets he was your pimp
yeah basically but i didn't know what a
pimp was that i thought it was my
boyfriend
yeah you know and uh i really liked him
and i would do anything he asked me to
do
um and he also used me as a surrogate
to have his baby for him and his wife
yeah and i didn't know that either i
thought he was in love with me and we're
gonna get married he's gonna leave his
wife
and we're gonna live happily ever after
that's not what happened
and so after my first child
um after him he he took her out of my
arms after he took her
i couldn't stand life anymore you know i
was by myself you know and i needed to
live and make
money and i um
i couldn't go back to my grandmother's
house i had left her
excuse me and um a little bit too grown
you know she wasn't gonna accept me
coming back
so i had to find my way in the streets
and
i met someone named eddie and he was the
most
gorgeous guy i mean he was so gorgeous
and like i said i was very timid and
easily led
and um i would do anything you know for
a guy that likes me you know i just
wanted to be liked
you know by someone so he introduced me
to
he let me know that he was a pimp this
is where i found out what a pimp was
um to be vegas
you know he's always talked about how
beautiful i was i hear lots of men tell
me how pretty i am
and i don't see the same thing everyone
sees you know
i even now today i get so many guys tell
me you know oh my god you're so
beautiful and
it kind of makes me bothers me when
someone tells me that
you know because that's all i've been
known for that's
all you know i mean men have ever told
me and
the men that have have told me that
nothing has
occurred i mean nothing has stemmed from
it nothing has
become of it you know what i mean yeah
i'm beautiful and everything but now
what have you been in love before
huh have you been in love before i think
so
i'm not really sure i'm not really sure
you know but your relationships haven't
worked out none of them i mean
no none of them that worked out i always
end up alone
um i have some issues with men
and the word love um
because i haven't had the experience of
being loved well i would think this
the upbringing you had and then the the
work that you've done
kind of paves the way for that to be the
case yeah because i'm kind of confused a
little bit
you know i really don't even now i don't
even want to be loved
whatever that may be i just want someone
who cares about me enough not to hurt me
yeah hold you yeah i'm 32.
i just want someone who loves me that's
about to hurt me that's it you know
um and at this point even right now it's
just like
i still haven't had the experience that
experience so
for them to tell me that i'm beautiful
really makes me feel it doesn't make me
feel good
because that only you know you're just
looking at my outside you're not looking
inside you know what i mean
and beauty's not gotten me anywhere you
know
um it's not where i want it to be
um prostitution that
got me the attention that i needed it
got the attention that i needed
you know what i mean it boosted your
self-esteem
it boosted your self-esteem most
definitely most definitely even though i
still couldn't really see what everybody
else
saw you know um i could act like it
you know and that would kind of cover up
what i felt
about myself because i i really felt
like they just used me for my body or
because i'm beautiful it's not really
gotten me anywhere
unless i don't have a husband you know i
mean um
i don't have a man in my life that cares
enough about me not to hurt me
you know i'm still paying my bills
myself and taking care of myself
but i'm so beautiful you know so why
can't i have someone who
loves me i don't know maybe there's
something i'm doing wrong i don't know
when you say loves you enough to hurt to
not hurt you does not hurt me
hurt you physically or just break your
heart both both breaking my heart
cares about you know cares about me you
know wants to see me smile
wants to make me happy wants to make me
feel good you know
wants me to i deserve that you know what
i mean and i want someone else to see
that
i deserve it absolutely and someone to
give it to me without
having to think about giving to me just
wanting me to have it
you know i know i feel good when i make
somebody else feel good
and that's another thing they call me
sharbat
some of my friends call me sharbat and
they call me sharbat because like a
robot
and that's because i'm always trying to
please somebody else i go out of my way
you know to please someone else because
really they think it's a bad thing but
all i want to do is see you smile
and knowing that i did that makes me
feel good because i did that you know i
mean
i was able to make you happy or you know
give you what you wanted that feels good
to me
you know and some people take advantage
of that
and men have especially taken advantage
of that
so so you your your career continued on
with other pimps or
well i've only had just like the real
pimp was
eddie the one who took me to vegas um
like i said i thought that i loved him
you know i mean
i was more attracted to his way he
dressed and
his style and how women flocked to him
you know i mean
and knowing that he liked me and i was
just that one that he slept with every
night
like i said i would do anything he
wanted me to do and
prostitution in vegas was fun
it was fun because it was plentiful you
know and there were so many men who
wanted me and
you know and that made him happy because
i was bringing him money
you know what i mean and as long as i
can bring him money i know i can keep
him
you know is that what the the basis of
the prostitutes
uh prostitutes attraction to a pimp is
is that you're
you're getting a high caliber man well
that's why i mean a man that wants you
man that's willing to keep you one
that's not gonna throw you away
you know yeah but you're working for him
yeah well that's
more reason for him to keep you you know
he may not really be attracted to you
the way you're attracted to him
you know he may act like it but he's
going to give you what you want and what
you need because you're making money for
him
you know but did you did you recognize
at the time that
it's not an ideal relationship that it's
somewhat abusive
not at all i didn't think anything was
wrong with it
that's the strange part you know i
really thought that he
he liked me he loved me he wanted to be
with me but now
years later you you do you see that yeah
most definitely okay
it's a form of abuse most definitely i
see that yeah that's why i'm not with
the pimps
it's just interesting that there are so
many women that are willing to do this
i mean actually um whatever man says
do you know there's got to be some
connection there something that he has
that you
you know that makes you do you want to
do this you know what i mean
and like i said i was on my own and he
took care of me
he took care of all my needs i didn't
have to worry about having a place to
sleep
eat i had a car clothes you know
all you have to do is go out making some
money i later realized that
your boyfriend is not gonna let you
sleep with another man
you know your man's not gonna let you
sleep with another man and if he does he
doesn't really care about you
he's using you you know um for whatever
he
use you for but the attraction
was the fame the lights having the money
and
putting on the clothes and going to the
casinos and
all the you know men looking at you and
just being that
to this day i'm still like that you know
i still like the to dress up and be
pretty and
walk and everybody you know turn heads
in the room you know
i don't i'm always late i'm i don't care
what you say i'm gonna be late
i let everyone know this i try my best
to be on time but i'm gonna be late
and really i like being late because i
want to arrive
i want to arrive i want everyone to look
at me when i walk in the room
they're done looking at everybody else
but i'm late i'm the one coming in last
so and then when they see me their heads
and everybody's like wow
you know i like that attention yeah and
where do you work today
ah favorite role i work everywhere yeah
everywhere wherever you know there's
money are you working
as a renegade or with a pimp i'm gonna
get again by myself
i'm older now and my experience with men
have not been that great
because i want more now i want more
um like that um i want a house i want
i want to pay people i want although i'm
prostitute
i prostitute to take care of me you know
and i like nice things i've always had
everything i wanted as a child so
you know i still want to have everything
you know i like to buy clothes every day
i want something new on every day i want
to wig every day
you know i make enough money to do that
it doesn't go into man's pocket it goes
in mine
you know i paid my phone bill you know i
don't want to have to ask a man for
nothing because when you do
they want something in return are you
hoping for a prince charming to come and
save the day
kind of sort of yeah i hear that a lot
from the girls yeah yeah
and i'm still waiting yes if that was to
ever happen
do you think you'd actually be able to
allow it to happen or you think you
might
sabotage it i'm scared of sabotaging it
yeah because i've had
offers i suspect that would happen i
most definitely would i would because
like i said i don't really believe that
there's
because of my experience i don't believe
that there's one that can
actually want to be with me and just me
only you know i believe that every man
cheats
because every man i've been with if i
had a wife or something relationship and
they've been with me
you know i haven't had a man that just
wants me and wants me only
you know um
i even find myself when i did what i do
or when i did find a man that i liked
i'd
offer him the threesome just so we can
get it over with
you know to see if he really wants to be
with me or doesn't want somebody else
you know um or if i'm enough compared to
her
or you know cuz i said i never really
felt like i was good enough
because every man i've had has cheated
on me
do you see now that you're a little bit
older do you see the flaws in your
thinking
almost definitely because i i mean
that's an outsider look at you like
you're a beautiful woman
you deserve a guy that is faithful to
you absolutely end of story
yeah yeah that's it no games no no
extras no
no you shouldn't have you didn't have to
give me your money you shouldn't have to
know that
none of that if he really cares about
you yeah yeah i
just i think maybe the childhood maybe
the the work you've done has
tainted you or changed your thinking
perception yeah
yeah it's kind of got me you know a
little confused a little bit
but like i said i am waiting to see if
um someone comes along
there's got to be someone somewhere you
know um
absolutely that cares about me i
couldn't you know then i guess you have
to work on being able to accept it
yeah know how to and i i kind of push
guys away
you know i kind of push them away that's
the self-sabotage yeah
um guy wants me to just call him and let
him know that i made it home safely
i can't pull it off um come see him
spend some time with him come watch a
movie with him
i can't pull it off i to be that close
to someone i'm scared to get
really i'm scared to get caught up with
my feelings with that person
because i'm scared that they're going to
leave me and then i'm going to be left
with that hurt and that pain
that i have to face every time that
doesn't feel good
you know that makes me do things to
myself you know it makes me hurt me even
more
you know i just want to be good enough
you know
i don't always want to be a prostitute
you know
i'd like to give that lifestyle up um
i'd like to live a normal life
i i i've got to have some type of
normality and i try to include that
in to my day although i do what i do you
know um
i try to do some things outside of being
a whole um
i try to dress a certain way so i can
feel better about myself because it does
affect my self-esteem
you know and when i do meet that someone
i don't want him thinking oh you're a
hoe or you're ex-ho or
you know i don't want that you know i
want a man who sees my value
you know and someone who motivates me to
be
better than i am you know um being sexy
is not good enough
being beautiful is not good enough it's
never worked for me
thank you for the compliment but no you
know please don't love me
don't love me i don't don't even use the
word love that's gonna push me away
just care about me enough and let me see
it in your actions don't tell me a whole
bunch of stuff about
what you're gonna do for me and how
you're gonna make me how you change my
life and
i hear that so much and nothing stem
smart
i'll know when you care about me you
know
that's all i want you know i know that
i'm a good person
and i know i deserve it but it's like
what am i doing wrong
to where i'm not meeting this man or
am i not in the right places at the
right time
um do i need to change my environment
um what do i do and then when i meet him
like he said what am i gonna do
how am i gonna i'm gonna handle it you
know i'd probably be a
bundle of nerves i probably wouldn't
know how to sit across the table
and talk to him you know i have a normal
conversation
you know i probably would be waiting
hurry up when we get into this good part
you know or let's hurry up and do this
so you know and
uh i'm cheating myself yeah you are you
know i'm cheating myself so
what emotions do you deal with do you do
like anxiety or depression or
anger depression anxiety most definitely
anxiety right now
is one of the things that i deal with a
lot i panic
over what
if he likes me too much or i don't want
him to get too caught up
you know or i get nervous um
you know um if he really feels something
for or if
it feels good i'm scared of feeling that
anything sexual if it feels good that's
yeah to feel good scares me sexually
if i actually like the guy i meet or
something i you know he's not a bad guy
i like him
i get all nervous and stuff i can't deal
with it
you know what i mean i don't want him
i don't know i don't want like i said i
don't want to get caught up in the
motions where it hurts
i don't want anything to hurt so like i
said even if he did if it was real i
wouldn't know
or i'd push him away because i don't
want to hurt i've hurt so
much that's all i know you know so it's
like hey
how's that he really likes you okay
you know you know and you know well
can't you see all the trouble he's going
i wouldn't i pushed him away i can't
take it
and i panic and it makes me all nervous
and stuff you know i don't think it's
real i don't believe in it i haven't
found anyone yet
you know someone who calls me and
concerned about having eaten
you know um do you have any money are
you
do you need anything you know what i
mean are you okay for today
um is there anything i can do for you
any no one's
ever concerned about me or what they can
do for me to help me if i need anything
you know i'm always like i said i work
extra extra hard
to make everybody else happy make sure
everybody has what they need so that
they don't
portray their their stuff on me you know
let me take care of you now
so you have what you and what do you
need and what okay what can i do for you
okay let's make it happen it sounds like
to me it sounds like
believing in yourself is what's what's
lacking that's it
you you need to believe that you deserve
somebody that does that that's not
not hope for it that's it that's exactly
i need that motivation i need to know
that
i'm that that you say i am all right i
want to be on the outside looking at i
can tell you a thousand times that
that's the case it is the k
it is the case but you need to feel it
yeah i want to be on the outside looking
in so i can see what everybody else sees
you know i mean it's just not good
enough you know
because if it was so why am i here
why am i here why can't i i see many
women
ugly as hell excuse me you know
they have a good man they're married
they have the life they want
what's wrong with me so beauty for me
doesn't cover it doesn't cut it
you know i know i have a wonderful
personality you know
i know that i'm intelligent i have a lot
of information i'm smart
you know i've been to school i got
degrees i've done everything that i
needed to do
but i'm still a prostitute but you're
not believing in yourself
it's a common one i think yeah so
are you saving money no
i actually have a lot of money coming in
but i just got a bank account recently
and um someone told me you know
charmaine try to put
to put away 20 a day if you can in the
bank
i'm going to start doing this next week
when i get more money but
um no i haven't been saving any money i
actually even moved in
under someone else to live with me um i
don't like living alone either by the
way
i don't like being alone period and that
subjects me to a lot of stuff
you know because people use me because i
have my own house and
you know stuff like that they come and
lay up on me and
men tell me they love me they want to be
with me and it's just because they don't
have a place to stay or
you know um i have no income other than
prostitution gr
and um ihss
i get someone takes care of me and gets
paid and we split the check
um
i'm about to get some money from um
a settlement and i have some
other money coming in but what i plan to
do with this money
is to put down on a house
because i have children and
grandchildren i have four girls
grandkids i have two
and no one ever left anything for me
no one cared enough about me to leave
anything behind for me or worried about
what would happen if i didn't have it
so i don't want that to be the case for
my children and grandchildren
and even if it's not much you know um
i would like to leave something behind
so that they don't have to do what i did
and go through what i went through or
going through
so i don't want to prostitute anymore
um i'm just doing it basically to
survive
did you ever enjoy it no yeah
do you think any of the girls respect or
did they enjoy it yeah oh yeah most
definitely yeah myself
yeah i have one girlfriend she's the
she's
she's like ah yes i do this i'm oh and
she tells her kids that
how could you ever i would not want my
kids to
ever know that i did that or to see
that to think that about me you know i
mean because i don't think that it's a
good thing
you know i'm not proud of it at all but
it's my means of survival
do you do you respect the men that pick
you up
no not really now some
i have you know um
the ones i guess was committed to just
seeing me
um yeah but no
so do you do you think this helps your
self-esteem or it hurts it or does it
hurts
most definitely it hurts
yeah yeah
what's the hardest part of doing this
just it under
it gets you down ah
what's the hardest part of doing it
having to do something you don't want to
do with someone you don't want to do it
with
it's work isn't it most definitely you
have bad experiences
i have you know i've been fortunate i
have not a lot of girls tell me to help
yeah i haven't been thrown out of a car
i haven't been raped i haven't
had none of that type of stuff happen
but i think that's because just the
person that i am
you know that hasn't happened but yeah
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is
about doing this kind of work do i like
it
yeah i like it
yeah that's interesting isn't it people
drive up and down figaro and they think
oh yeah these girls are all into it
well i'm good at it but you know i don't
like it
and i like to please a man i most
definitely like to please a man
and i like him to feel good and but it's
the man that i choose that i want
that to happen for not just every man
what was the best time of your life i'm
trying to think
i don't think i've gotten there yet what
was the worst time of your life
a kid's being taken you know you didn't
my daughter being taken out of my arms
the first the first time you told me
about yeah yeah and i have to find out
that he really didn't love me and that
he was using me so i can have a baby for
him and his wife
that yeah that's horrible yeah did you
raise your other kids
yes i have a set of twins and i have a
21 year old 22 year old now but yeah
do you think you're addicted to this
this life not at all no
no give it up in a minute yeah yeah
like tonight i'm going home and i'm
gonna go well i'm gonna go to ralph's
and i'm going to get 14 bell peppers
because i'm going home to make stuffed
bell peppers
why 14 when there's only two of us that
live in my household but so i can feed
everyone else
yeah i actually like being at home
and um like i said my roommate she's a
girl i like taking care of her too you
know i've gotta
i need someone there that i can take
care of or someone who
i know that's there for me you have a
big you have a big heart for everyone
else
that's the problem everyone and the
people that know that you need to take
care of yourself
yeah i don't know how to do that i don't
that's wrong i don't know how to do that
i think it's common though
it's not just you i see it a lot
especially in this line of work
yeah it's like
it's like the reason these girls get in
these relationships with these pimps or
the reason they
can't get a a real man in their life is
they just can't accept it
yeah yeah but i'm starting to come
around
you know i think i deserve it you're
smart enough and that's why i don't i'm
not accepting a lot of things anymore
um certain things i don't go for anymore
because i know the difference from the
experience that i've had
previously you know and yeah i need to
know that i deserve it
you know i start therapy next week oh
good for you
which is a big thing have you have you
had that before
oh that'll be great for you um yeah i'm
starting some therapy
and i hope that that helps bring about
some change
because i have a young girl who stays
with me and
who's in this line of work and i want
her to see something different i don't
know what it is
um she's saying mage is my daughter
and i don't know what it is about her
but
i see me in her and i don't want her to
have to suffer
because there's so much that comes along
with it and she's worth it
but i can see that in her but why i
can't see none of myself
i just have to figure some things out so
i think i need to go to therapists and
do um a little bit therapy trying to
find out what's going on
yeah therapy would be really great i'm
looking forward to it yeah
good luck with that thanks all right hot
topic thank you so much for
sharing your story and i wish you the
best of luck with your with your
therapist
okay thank you thank you very much